RIGHT NOW, BRET.
>> Bret: KEVIN CORKE LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
NEW MOVEMENT IN THE
EVER-CHANGING, EVER INCREASING
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
FIELD.
FORMER GOVERNOR AND A BIG CITY
MAYOR IS IN.
FORMER OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOT.
THE FRONT RUNNER AMONG DECLARED
CANDIDATES SEEKING TO SOLIDIFY
HIS SOCIALIST CREDENTIALS.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY SHOWS
US WHERE THINGS STAND TONIGHT.
>> THE FIRST WAVE OF 2020
CANDIDATES CAME FROM CONGRESS.
THE NEXT WAVE IS COMING FROM
STATE HOUSES.
>> I AM JOHN HICKENLOOPER.
I AM RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
BECAUSE WE ARE FACING A CRISIS
THAT THREATENS EVERYTHING WE
STAND FOR.
>> THE FORMER COLORADO
GOVERNOR JOINS A FIELD WHERE
MANY OF THE MOST EXCITED PRIMARY
VOTERS HAVE MADE UP THEIR MINDS.
THIS WEEKEND, 12,500 SCREAMING
FANS TURNED OUT IN CHICAGO NOT
TO CHEER FOR THE SPORTS TEAMS
BUT FOR BERNIE.
>> THREE YEARS AGO THEY THOUGHT
WE WERE KIND OF CRAZY AND
EXTREME.
NOT THE CASE ANYMORE.
>> SENATOR SANDERS TOOK HIS
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PITCH TO
THE RADIO WHERE HE PLEDGED TO
LEGALIZE POT.
>> HAVE YOU EVER SMOKED?
>> A FEW TIMES.
DIDN'T DO A WHOLE LOT FOR ME.
>> THE 2020 FIELD WON'T INCLUDE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER WHO WANTS TO FOCUS ON
REDISTRICTING AND RIGHTS IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IN
DEVALUING POTENTIAL NOMINEES, WE
SHOULD REMEMBER THE CREATIVITY
IS NOT LIMITED TO THE YOUNG, NOR
WISDOM TO THOSE WHO ARE OLDER.
WE MUST MEASURE OUR CANDIDATES
NOT BY THEIR AGE BUT THE
VITALITY OF THEIR IDEAS.
SOME OF THOSE IDEAS WERE ON
DISPLAY IN SELMA, ALABAMA.
>> WE ARE FAILING OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION WHEN RIGHT HERE IN
SELMA, TOO MANY CHILDREN ARE
DYING DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE AND
HOW EASY THESE GUNS ARE GETTING
IN OUR STREETS.
>> IN SELMA, 2020 CANDIDATE AND
NEW JERSEY SENATOR CORY BOOKER
WAS SEEN HUGGING THE 2016 KNOW
MANY HILLARY CLINTON WHOSE
FAMILY BRAND IS APPARENTLY
FADING.
THE AP REPORTS HER HUSBAND ABOUT
ONCE A TOP SURROGATE, LIKELY
WILL BE NEXT YEAR BECAUSE "SO
FAR NONE OF THE PARTIES EARLY
FRONT RUNNERS HAVE HAD A FORMAL
MEETING WITH CLINTON, NOR HAVE
THE WOMEN WHO ARE RUNNING AN
HISTORICALLY DIVERSE PRIMARY
FIELD."
OHIO SENATOR SHERROD BROWN SAYS
HE'S TWO OR THREE WEEKS AWAY
FROM A DECISION ON THE CAMPAIGN
AND HAVE A CHANCE TO CHECK IN
WITH HILLARY IN SELMA BUT
PASSED.
>> DID SENATOR CLINTON GIVE YOU
ANY ADVICE?
>> NO.
>> "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
NBC NEWS POLL FINDS
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEGINS HIS
REELECTION EFFORT WITH
4 OUT OF 10 VOTERS SAYING THEY
WILL DEFINITELY OR PROBABLY VOTE
FOR HIM.